puerto rico je suis venu ici à la recherche d'
une histoire qui s'appelle du journalisme ton
CV n'a pas l'air si anxieux je n'aurais pas
payé ton hôtel si je ne
t'avais pas déjà embauché mais j'ai trouvé le
paradis le plus étrange sur terre hé c'est
là que ton  les secrets viennent danser ne
remarquez pas la perruque et le vaudou fonctionne c'est
magique laissez boire ne vous
cause pas d'ennuis comment quelqu'un boit-il
cent soixante et une miniatures ils ne sont
pas gratuits hé les femmes
certainement je pensais que peut-être vous  était un triton
Je viens du Connecticut Je sais que Arriba
reste loin d'elle elle est
fiancée de Sanderson juste quelques jours dans les nouvelles prenez-
le comme au Maroc elle est une douce petite
beauté Je regardais son bateau nous avons
tous été sur elle c'est  une
expérience merveilleuse maintenant tout cela peut sembler
une élucidation folle
mais tout est vrai je pense que
c'est un endroit pour voir de l'argent Paul il y a des
gens comme moi tu sais comment le
sortir n'est pas ce genre de chose tout
c'est un commentaire inapproprié nous  J'ai
cloué ce bâtard à sa propre
porte d'entrée J'ai une histoire pour toi qui te poursuit
hors de ton esprit Je parie que tu as crié
avant moi
parce que ce truc est des chambres défectueuses
as-tu prouvé que l'alcool
ce que nous faisons est privé
Franzese parti j'ai  j'ai une idée géniale
essaie d'avoir l'air normal